quand ses parents se sont séparés
juliette avait 4 ans à peine et une
certitude elle voulait voir son père
autant que sa mère ainsi en avait-elle
décidé alors ses parents ont dû faire la
paix pour organiser sa nouvelle vie je
suis françois l'habitude aujourd'hui le
lundi je suis avec ma mère le mardi soir
choix on perd le mercredi je fais avec
mon père le jeudi soir chez eux avec ma
mère et le vendredi
une fois avec nommé ron cohen au premier
abord ça paraît compliqué mais pour
juliette
rien de plus simple trois jours chez son
père trois jours chez sa mère une
alternance très organisés mais qui a un
coût car pour ce qui est de sa famille
son turbo a dû se résigner à moi
travailler ouais j'ai eu l'opportunité
en fait d'avoir un travail à temps
partiel
donc j'ai pu récupérer une journée que
je que je dédie à ma grande fille donc
le mercredi en fait on fait tout ce
qu'on a à faire en ce moment c'est ses
musiques et l'arrière chez les piscines
aussi les loisirs l'habillement le
logement finalement franck turbo a les
mêmes charges familiales que son
ex-épouse laissant avoir accès aux aides
sociales
les esprits aujourd'hui ne sont
attribuées qu'à un seul des parents
celui qui obtient du juge la résidence
de l'enfant en tant que père séparé ou
divorcé ces ferrailles puisque la
résidence étaient confiés et chez la
mère on a droit elle strictement à rien
l'allocation logement jeune hacker sur
logement on n'y a pas accès ou très peu
les fameuses primes de rentrée scolaire
qui sont pas des visages du tout c'est
également la mère qui en bénéficient
chaque ami le 1500 francs c'est pas rien
non plus il n'y a pas de différenciation
à faire entre un père et une mère
surtout quand il s'agit de l'éducation
de l'enfant ces campements anormal que
tout aille du même côté il y rien
d'autre en donnant aux pères divorcés
l'accès aux prestations sociales
ségolène royal veut les encourager à
élever leurs enfants malgré la
séparation car aujourd'hui en france un
enfant sur deux ne voit plus son père
après le divorce